بدأت مسابقة ترعاها الدولة اليوم
لاصطياد الثعابين البورمية في دائمة الخضرة ، حيث
كانت الثعابين الغازية تعيث فسادا
لسنوات وهي تأكل الثدييات
والطيور المحلية التي
تنضم إلينا الآن دونا خليل واحدة
من صائدي الثعابين التي ستكون جزءًا
من المسابقة
التي كانت أولها  أنثى لتصبح
اختصاصية في القضاء على الثعابين مرخصة من الدولة
في فلوريدا. أحب فلوريدا
أولاً أخبرنا عن هذه الثعابين ،
أعني مقدار
المشاكل التي تسببها نعم
لقد تسببوا في الكثير من المشاكل أه
هنا في ولاية فلوريدا في الجزء
الجنوبي
من فلوريدا  لقد أكلوا
ما يقرب من 98 حيوانًا في
حديقة إيفرجليدز
الوطنية وهم يعملون في طريقهم شمالًا
ونحاول منعهم ،
لذلك تم إعداد تحديات الثعبان
أساسًا لتثقيف
الجمهور حول كيفية مساعدتهم
دون كيف يمكنك التقاط أحد
هذه الأشياء يدويًا ، فأنت في الأساس تخرج
في إيفرجليدز أم لدي سيارة
أقود بها السدود
والطرق الموجودة هناك في إيفرجليدز
و ج  خسر في المنزل أيضًا
وابحث عنهم ونحن في
الأساس نطارد الصيادين
أه هم هناك عادة في
الليل ونذهب إلى هناك في الليل
أه نطاردهم وبمجرد أن
نصادفهم فإنهم في الواقع يتحركون ببطء شديد
لأنهم يصطادون إنهم
صائدوا الكمائن ، لذا فهم يتحركون
ببطء
شديد وإذا تسللت وأمسكتهم
بيدك ثم
تبدأ الإثارة كما تعلم اعتمادًا
على حجم هذا الثعبان
تعطيك فرصة للحصول على أموالك ،
عليك أن تصارعها ،
هذا ما أريد أن أعرف أنك
تصارعه بيديك العاريتين ،
نعم ، أنت تتأكد من أنه لا يلتف
حول عنقك أو أي شيء آخر أه
لا تفعله  لا يريدون خنقًا
لأن هذا ما يفعلونه ، فهم ليسوا
سامين
وهم مقيدون ، وللتوضيح فقط ،
إذا صادفت
أحدهم هنا في جنوب فلوريدا
، فما عليك سوى إلقاء نظرة عليه ، وسوف ينظر
إليك "  سأستدير وأذهب بعيدًا ،
كانت هذه حيوانات أليفة منذ 40 عامًا ، واه
الآن  الحيوانات الأليفة ، تلك
التي نصطادها لم تعد حيوانات أليفة بعد الآن ،
إنها 12 13 14 جيلًا من
كونها حيوانات أليفة
لكنها لا تزال ، نعم ، لقد تم
جلبها من خلال تجارة الحيوانات الأليفة
وكانت حيوانات أليفة مثل القطط والكلاب تمامًا
أعرف أن الكثير من الناس لديهم أكثر من مليون
شخص لديهم ثعابين أليفه ، لقد اعتدت
الاحتفاظ بها
أيضًا في الواقع لدي واحدة الآن لأن
شخصًا ما
سمح لها بالخروج في إيفرجليدز
ووجدتها وهي ليست ثعبان بورمي
إنها كرة  الثعبان ،
لذا فهم لا أه ، أعتقد حقًا أن
البورميون الذين يجرون الجوائز يجب أن تكون أكبر
مقابل هذا المبلغ الذي تبلغ
قيمته خمس وعشرونمائة دولار ، ويبدو أن 1500 دولار
يجب أن تكسب المزيد من المال ولكن علينا
أن نختتم
هنا بالجلود التي أعتقد أنها  هذا خلفك ،
نعم ، هذا
هو أول واحد أمسكته ، إنه 12
قدمًا ، آه ثعبان اشتعلت به في
حديقة السرو الوطنية الكبيرة وأه
الثاني هو الذي حصلت عليه مع أخي.
جنوب فلوريدا إدارة المياه ل
وكمقاول ثعبان ، فهما
كلاهما 12
قدمًا واه ليس الأكبر الذي أمسك به ،
فلدي 15 قدمًا ونصف هذا هو أكبر ما لدي ،
لكن الأكبر هو 18 قدمًا ، آه
تسعة وتسع وربع بوصات أه
أنت  أعلم ، هذا نعم ، إنها
وحوش ، إنها وحوش ، نحتاج إلى المساعدة
، فلننزل